my sky descending into algebras deep
where no human has been before but in
the first ever live programs from the
twilight zone sky presenters brought
home the Wonder there were sharks raised
and groupers and always the
extraordinary backdrop of what could at
times have been another planet i
broadcast from some pretty remote and
amazing places in my time but none quite
so remote or amazing as this algebras
waters have been protected from human
exploitation and it shows even in the
deep which scientists once assumed was
barren that was life algebra is known as
the Galapagos of the Indian Ocean not
just because of the richness of life in
its waters but also the unusual life on
land and here there are 150,000 of these
guys giant tortoises but plastic is the
scourge of Aldabra the tortoises have a
taste for it
this Ibis will probably die from it
turtles do their best to nest in it
volunteers from the Aldabra cleanup
project how to remove 50 tons of plastic
from the at all fishing gear bottles and
more than fifty thousand flip-flops we
know for sure that this cannot stay here
so we still consider that it's been very
worthwhile to get this stuff off here
but yes we're hoping to use this to
motivate the rest of the world to solve
this problem in a much more sensible way
back in the UK school children put their
questions to some of the world's ocean
experts how many years would it take to
remove all the rubbish from the ocean
well that is a good question
removes rubbish that's being put into
the ocean I mean that's enough not
possible some of it is still on the
surface of the water but majority is
fragmented and down at the bottom from
sharks and the shallows an inquisitive
fish on the reef to the perpetual
darkness below we hope our journey was
immersive a rallying cry for the sea in
a warming world that was deep ocean life
Thomas More Sky News Aldabra
and just to let you know that you can
catch up with the very best of the three
days of coverage from the deep in our
highlights program that's at nine
o'clock on Friday evening right here on
Sky News and don't forget you can also
keep up to date with our deep ocean
project on the sky knees website and
also the mobile app